يجمعهم موقف واحد بخصوص الحرب في اوكرانيا
وتفرقهم مواقفهم المتعارضه المتصله
بمصالحهم الاقتصاديه اوروبا والولايات
المتحده على طرفين ايضا بخصوص قانون
مكافحه التضخم الامريكي المانيا انتقدت
السياسه الاقتصاديه لواشنطن محذره على
لسان وزيرها في الماليه من اندلاع حرب
تجاريه مع الولايات المتحده فعل العكس من
الاقتصاد الفرنسي تقول برلين ان اقتصادها
مرتبط بشكل وثيق بالسوق الامريكيه والا
مصلحه لها في حرب تجاريه مع واشنطن من
جانبه اثار الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون والقضيه خلال زيارته الرسميه
للولايات المتحده وحذر من ان القانون
سيخلق فوارق كبيره لن تدفع العديد من
الشركه للاستثمار في اوروبا
الاليزيا يعتبر الامر تهديدا بحدوث انقسام
الغرب
اقرب عن رغبته في تسويه مساله الاعفاءات
التجاريه التي يطلب الاتحاد الاوروبي من
الولايات المتحده ادراجها في خطتها الخاصه
بالمناخ بحلول الربع الاول من العام
المقبل قانون مكافحه التضخم الامريكي نصف
على استثمارات بالمليارات في حمايه المناخ
وترتبط الاعانات والاعفاءات الضريبيه
بالشركات التي تستخدم المنتجات الامريكيه
او تلك التي تنتج في الولايات المتحده
ماجر عليها انتقادات اوروبا بلال
البوجداني العربيه